en fait je croyais que j'avais la visée
de mon fils aujourd'hui
et là je me découvre gentiment ou totaux
témoin voilà et puis qu'est-ce qu'il est
beau mon fils je vais au plus bas et ma
conviction de seconder mais voyez dans
le ton que vous utilisez pour raconter
cette rencontre vous avez dit quelques
instants il ya une différence avec ce
qu'on a entendu vous n'avez pas honte de
votre père vous ne le renie et pas vous
en avez même l'air d'être fiers même
aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est la fierté le mot qui
convient éric à la récréation moi je
vous dis bien quand on joue et méchant
enfin moi je jouais souvent le rôle de
mesrine j'aurais jamais joué le rôle
d'amy louis michel fourniret est elle
est là la différence quand on jouait le
méchant joue et mesrine sélection c'est
un bon argument
l'intéressé c'est ça c'est sétif hier à
l'époque vous l'êtes encore aujourd'hui
est-ce que fierté le mot qui convient je
sais pas je fête bières fierté oui oui
et oui quelque part dans le sud bien sûr
je suis fier que mon père mon père c'est
pas le sien c'est pas le sien désolé
mais vous comprenez vous avez entendu
dans leur sort pas du tout la manière
pas du tout la lame est le meilleur dans
les fusibles a grandi avec eux de ce
genre de souffrance en fait moi même la
souffrance a été plus l'absence de mon
père plutôt que critiquer c'est tout
comme sa présence mois de l'année pour
moi moi j'avais là où je l'avais le plus
souvent c'est au parloir c'est là vous
avez l'occasion de voir le plus souvent
et le plus tranquillement possible vous
celle inverse la prison c'est totalement
la mer moi moi c'était presque bien au
bout d'un moment d'y aller parce que moi
je le voyais ce qui était plus terrer
pour moi ça va être sans son assassinat
parce que comme dirait l'autre je suis
certainement à des seuils gamins dans ce
pays où son père s'est fait fi de cette
manière quoi on va revenir là dessus
mais quand vous après l'ancien des oui
oui oui mais quand vous entendez les
flics je suis pas c'est pas mon dieu
d'accord parce que non je voulais savoir
c'est pour ça que nous interroger sur
nos fierté parce que quand vous entendez
ce grand flic là qui dit ne nous
trompons pas c'est un tueur très violent
sadique
y'a pas brassé pas une idole quoi je
veux vous êtes votre fils d'un point de
vue très particulier mais j'ai mon père
d'un côté et je fais un français comme
les autres hein mon père c'est une idole
plus c'est aussi mon idole merrick dit
que c'est un tueur mais il a été
assassiné par la police
c'est un braqueur de banque etc
mais c'est pas un tueur la journée à
travers et il ya 2 milliards de chasse
le garder mais je suis d'accord mais il
faut savoir que les gardiens
il faut savoir que les gardes-chasse
okada s'est pas les guerres de chasse en
france 1 pincée de vie par daba cm qui
célébrait ses deux vies celle au
champion je suis d'accord mais je
voudrais vous expliquer lé contexte
quand même et eux ont été repérés parce
qu'ils étaient en train de faire de
l'entraînement tiers dans une forêt les
gardes-chasse les ont braqué directement
et en mairie les oraux connus
immédiatement et qui a tiré le premier
c'est le complice de mon père qui a tiré
il a été condamné à 2 x 125 ans de
prison dont 1 6 du ca lui donne entendu
société oui on ne sent pas et vous sa
production avec les chasser mon père a
rajouté une balle pour chacun comme si
les deux si les deux se faisait rigoler
mais elle est là la peine il a partagé
en deux voilà c'est plus un geste
débilos d'amitié si on peut dire mais
c'est pas lui qui les a tués non mais je
me permets d'insister alors c'est
peut-être un peu de mauvais goût vous
êtes son fils à l'abri mais il a déjà un
panda les uns d'accord mais je me
permets d'insister parce que il ya
malgré tout pour les gens qui sont pas
emile louis aux formes et les accords
ces deux cas une sorte de glorification
un peu du gangster une quelle votre père
elle a fait l'objet de sin d'ailleurs
d'excellents ci est joué par vincent
cassel qui à nos meilleurs acteurs des
plus charismatiques donc il ya quand
même pour des gens qui ont beaucoup de
choses sur la conscience et donc on l'a
rappelé un double meurtre est une forme
de glorification qui parfois moi me
dérange un peu voilà donc pour cela que
j'insiste je comprends mais c'est pas
moi qui ai fait de lui un héros un
d'abord c'est lui le plus grand vous
l'expliquer que la fascination continue
je pense que la fascination c'est la
manière dont il a été assassiné
ils sont ils auraient été arrêtées au
cours d'un hold up normalement ou
pourquoi pas tué au cours d'un hold up
pour papa sa part yves aussi un malgré
qu'il ait jamais tiré au cordeau le 2
octobre une fois sur les nombreux nombre
qu'il a fait ça serait bien passé pour
aider l'état la manière que voilà à
partir de là je crois qu'on comprend